So, let's just play this clip.
We need to focus on now Charlie Kirk's
memory be eternal. He's with the Lord
Jesus Christ. Many martyrs have died,
are dying, and martyrs that the world
does not even notice. Charlie Kirk is a
world famous figure.
What we saw take place
is a reminder of what's reality for
Christians around the world whom the
world does not know. So the Lord
allowing Charlie Kirk to be martyed
to finish the race. May we finish the
race and not shame the Lord not fall
away.
He had an impact because he was world
famous. But it was the Lord reminding
you this shook you. This shocked you
that Charlie Kirk got gunned down? Are
you aware right now there are Christians
in these parts of the world that are
being gunned down right now? And yet it
doesn't shock you or move you. So
Charlie Kirk is a reminder of what's
happening every day around the world.
Yes, Wy, I already mentioned that.
So, if you were troubled and shocked by
Charlie Kirk, that means you're living
too comfortably.
What do I mean? You're too comfortable
because you're living in an environment
where it doesn't cost you your life to
glorify Christ. You may lose your job,
but it won't get you gunned down.
And yet the world around you sees what
happened to Charlie Kirk as something
that is not out of the ordinary. Go to
Nigeria and ask the Christians, "Did you
see what they did, Charlie Kirk?"
They'll tell you, "This happens to us
every day. What are you talking about?"
Well, let me play this one important
clip, then we're going to get into the
topic because this will be it for me and
Charlie Kirk. Unless something else
happens. This is it. I've said my peace,
but I'm reminding you, don't diminish
his death, but don't make it more than
it is. Don't make him a hero if you're
not going to then make heroes of all
those unnamed martyrs who were in front
of their children and spouses
in these countries
whose names are not even mentioned
as Charlie Kirk's name is mentioned.
And yet they are known to the Lord,
beloved to the Lord. They are the true
Charlie Kirks. This is the part I want
to play and just we'll be done. Okay,
let's see here. Charlie Kirk refused to
listen. He was offered a trip to Israel.
He refused.
When the FBI could not locate
the alleged gunman on Wednesday,
>> watch. You know who stepped up and
offered a $1 million reward for
information leading to the arrest of
Charlie Kirk's assassin?
>> Now the rabbit hole gets deeper and
deeper. Who offered a $1 million reward?
And Candace Owens confirmed and Ana
Kasparian plays the clip. I'll play it
to you. And she says, "Yes." Watch,
guys. Who offered a million dollars?
>> Bill Aman.
>> Bill Aman. Now, who is he?
>> And just who do you think that $1
million will be paid out to?
>> It looks like it will be paid out to the
alleged killer's father.
>> Blackman is the millionaire.
I think he's even a billionaire.
pro-Israeli
Jewish supporter of
Charlie Kirk who
rebuked Charlie Kirk, harshly criticized
Charlie Kirk for bringing on folks like
Tucker Carlson, right? And even
questioning regime change. This is who
Blackman is.
Tyler Robinson was allegedly turned into
law enforcement by his father.
His Mormon father,
the Mormon father who turned in his gay
son dating a who killed Charlie Kirk
is going to get a $1 million payout from
Bill Aman.
>> See,
>> the man who according to friends of
Charlie Kirk menaced him. See the s same
Bill Aman who bullied Charlie Kirk
threatened him that he would not support
him turn against him because this is
what happens when you have the wrong
theology. Folks,
when you have the wrong theology and
you've been deceived by Christian
Zionism and you think that the modern
state of Israel is a necessary
fulfillment of prophecy and the Jews are
still God's chosen people and because
you've been duped by that theology, you
now bend over backwards to try to
support Israel. Then this what happens?
Then the billionaires who are all pro-
Israel, pro-Zionist,
right, Israelis or Jews or even Gentiles
will then pump billions in your pocket
in your organization to use you as their
PR guy, as their voice to get all the
evangelicals
to go on the side of the Israeli agenda.
But the moment you start maturing and
seeing h maybe I was wrong, maybe this
interpretation of the Bible is wrong
because it's recent. It's novel. It's
about 200 years old. And when you
carefully interpret the Old Testament
out of the New Testament, the true
people of God are the church. The true
Israel of God is Jesus. And any ethnic
Jew or Gentile who's baptized in Christ,
that Jew, that Gentile now becomes true
Israel, it's no longer the land, it's no
longer earthly Jerusalem, it's heavenly
Jerusalem and spiritual Israel, the
church. Once you start waking up, it's a
kind of a little too late. Why? because
you've already
bound yourself and have become a slave
to these billionaires who won't like it
if you don't tow the party line. You see
the problem? That's what happened to
Charlie Kirk.
That's what happened to Charlie Kirk. It
didn't help he had a praying Catholic
wife. Guys, you don't think that his
wife had an influence because you cannot
be a devout Catholic and think Israel is
still the chosen people of God in the
sense that the church is plan B. The
Catholic Church, the Orthodox Church,
the ancient Christians all taught the
true Israel of God is Christ and his
church, his body baptized by his spirit
into him. God will not wipe out the Jews
completely, but the Jew must be baptized
with the Gentile, and only then does the
Jew become God's chosen people.
You think his Catholic wife did not have
his ear, the fact he was praying the
rosary, the fact he was attending mass?
Of course,
they didn't like it. Bill Aman now and
puts a million dollars reward to find
the guy and that million dollars goes to
the kid's father because the father
turned them in. How convenient.
>> For not taking Netanyahu's money and
supporting Israel's war in Iran.
>> See,
>> do you think Bill Aman is just uh
generous?
>> Generous, huh?
>> He's a vigilante.
Put another way, the billionaire that
allegedly threatened
Charlie Kirk,
the the billionaire married to an
Israeli who took money from Jeffrey
Epstein,
who is by all credible observations
working on behalf of Israel in some
context.
The guy that apparently menaced Charlie
Kirk is the same guy who will pay a man
a million dollars for turning in his gay
son implicating him in the murder of
Charlie Kirk. See now Nick Fuentes has
some great points. Great. Remember you
don't th out the baby with the
bathwater. Remember be consistent. Let
us practice what we preach. We don't
throw out the baby with the bathwater.
He has phenomenal points and he's not
stupid. He's educated. He's a very
intelligent young man. It's the problem
is that in other areas he's so extreme
that he ruins it for himself when he
goes, "Go yourself. you, man.
you. You pucker."
You see, anybody find that a little bit
suspicious?
This is a tweet, a real tweet that Bill
Aman put out last week. He said, quote,
"A number of people have reached out
andor posted expressing concern that
Tyler Robinson's father may collect a
$1.2 million reward for turning in his
son." Which inspires a few thoughts.
First, in order for rewards to be
effective in finding criminals, the
rewards need to be paid even if the
recipient is a crook or worse.
>> Now, you guys are still missing the
point. Milin, sister, you're missing the
point. Whether the father took it or
not,
please stop the smoke and mirrors. Think
about what he said.
Bill Aman offered a million dollar
reward, which means it would be paid out
to the father of the child because he's
the one who gave in his son. Whether he
accepts it or not, you see why this is
demonic. Not you, Milan. But you're not
dumb, sister. You're a child of God.
Be wise. It's irrelevant if the father
took it. What's relevant is that Bill
Aman offered it, which means that the
reward must go to the father. Even if he
rejects it, then so be it. What are you
not getting? So the point here is why is
Bill Aman offering a million-doll reward
when he's the one who bullied and
threatened
Charlie Kirk for not towing the line and
agreeing with Netanyahu Netanyahu's
agenda for greater Israel and wipe out
the Middle East. What are you guys not
getting?
I mean, come on, man. Do I need to
explain this to you guys?
Man, dude, I thought I was stupid. Joey
Calaldian, they give hope to you and me,
huh? Anyway, this will be the last time
I'll talk. Why my last time? Not because
I'm afraid. God forbid that I fear. May
I fear Jesus and God make me bold even
unto death. In Jesus name, save me for
myself. It's because I'm not an expert
politician. I'm not an expert, guys. So,
I don't want to get into a topic if I'm
not an expert. I'm just going to give
you clips, give you the facts, you go
investigate because my ministry is
focused on biblical theology, ancient
Christian beliefs, the early church's
teachings, and how those doctrines
should affect and impact your politics,
your socioeconomic position, every
sphere of your life, because Jesus is
the Lord of every sphere of your life.
I'll give you the facts from church
history, from the scriptures. Let that
inform who your allegiance is to be to.
That said, in this case, if the father
is found to have been involved or
otherwise acted negligently in
contributing to Charlie's death, civil
litigation or criminal prosecution will
reverse unjust compensation.
I've also seen reports that suggest
Tyler's family intends to wave its right
to any reward. So, yes, we will pay the
reward if it is earned. See, Tyler's
favor family forfeits the right, you
know, the reward. They don't want it.
Okay, that's not the point. Get the
point.
Almost done.
>> To whomever the FBI indicates provided
the information that led to Tyler's
arrest.
>> To me, that might be the smoking gun.
That might be the connection that
slipped everybody's attention.
>> Yep. So, Bill Aman allegedly menaced
Charlie Kirk over Israel. Now, Bill Aman
is paying
>> menaced and Candace Owens confirms it.
speaking with Charlie Kirk. Charlie Kirk
actually confirmed it as well that after
he had a meeting where he was getting
blasted by the pro-Zionist, the
billionaires who are pumping money in
his organization, he then went on Megan
Kelly show and said, "You should see the
text I'm getting saying I'm an
anti-semite." He came out and said it.
He was being harassed. What do you guys
don't get? a million dollars to a Mormon
man turning in his gay son dating a
implicating him in the killing of
Charlie Kirk.
I see a bit of a conflict of interest
there.
>> Now, with that being said,
>> no, he's careful.
>> I'm not running with that.
>> Very careful. You see why I say Nick
Fuentes, you are an highly intelligent
young man. You are smart. You're not
stupid. May God purge, perfect, sanctify
you and I, all of us to be more
Christlike, less sinful, and God have
mercy on us and save us from our own
sins, hypocrisy.
Brilliant young man, you have a lot of
knowledge, a lot of insights, but we got
to tone it out on the pucking, man.
Please, man, stop telling people
yourself, you pucker. Go puck off, man.
>> I'm not stating that as fact. I'm saying
that requires careful scrutiny. It's not
a at the minimum there is the appearance
of impropriy. That's not a good look and
that needs to be investigated.
>> Yep.
>> And I credit that observation to Arthur
Bloom who's being investigated in
Virginia for calling somebody an Israeli
spy. Go figure. He put me on to this.
I'm not going to pretend I came up with
it myself. See, he's just going with
what he's hearing from those who are in
the know. Like Candace Own. She goes,
she was speaking to Charlie Kerr, one of
her best friends. They started together.
But at the minimum, that needs to be
investigated. And I'd be very interested
if the father receives that payout. If
he doesn't, then maybe there's nothing
there. But I find that to be very
conspicuous.
>> See, that's all he said. He didn't say
the father took it, you guys. He's
saying that the reward would go to the
father if he accepts it or not. But why
is Bill Aman offering a million-dollar
reward when he's the one who hammered
harassed Charlie Kirk for not towing the